hi uh my name is greg alba and i'm john
humphrey and we are the real rejects how
are you guys doing today
hi guys how are you doing
we are doing good uh we were talking
beforehand uh that this is the first
time in a while that we were actually
kind of nervous
because we've been watching both of you
since we were kids and so to be we're 54
years old
still being here yeah after all this
time
so uh thank you guys so much for uh
taking the time to talk with us we're
we're
big fans we're big fans um john why
don't you ask the first question
absolutely um so jimin uh you've been in
more comic book properties by now than
either of us can count across dc marvel
and beyond and reese i mean you had an
iconic turn as uh kirk connors and the
amazing spider-man so i'm curious as to
how this experience making this
particular comic book movie maybe stood
out from those and have the films
affected your relationship to just the
comic book medium as a whole uh jimin
when we start with you no i mean
if anything it enhanced my uh you know
my understanding of comic books and uh
certainly uh being part of this uh
interpretation of some of the comic
books uh it's it's lovely to see
suddenly the kingsman is sort of like uh
organic superheroes if you will
yeah
yeah there's no other film or of the
genre of the same genre where we all
you could view this uh these all these
characters on screen and still feel like
um
you belong right i mean they are human
like you you
potentially have the goods also to
emulate what they stand for as well you
know and
in that essence it's completely
different from the other superhero films
but also working with matthew was in a
way a discovery a shocking discovery
because i didn't realize how picky he
was about his action you know uh
sequences and um so that was a shocker
coming into it and obviously it was met
with a tremendous challenge a physical
challenge obviously i'm referring to the
the amazing fight sequence that uh rhys
and i had in uh
that is quite iconic in this film right
um you tend to succeed you know exceed
himself uh every time from the previous
film so anyway i'll let reese talk to
you about it
yeah i mean
you know i think the great thing about
you know i think
comic book
cinema is a kind of natural evolution
because the comic book is essentially a
storyboard
you know so they're they're very happy
bed fellows i think you know and i think
particularly in matthew's case matthew
um uses the camera like a graphic
novelist yeah um yeah um he he has an
exquisite sense of symmetry when he
wants us to uh
absorb
uh something in its 360-ness his camera
grammar is is amazing you know so he has
this great
classical sense of symmetry you know
like what we remember from all those
great old films from lawrence of arabia
and those films set on these vast kind
of
exquisite canvases but he also has the
dynamism of of um
making you feel like you're in the room
when there's violence
i've never worked with anyone who uses
the camera so um physically if you like
um and you're very consciously aware of
that the whole time you're working with
him he's 10 steps ahead it's almost like
he has like a
he doesn't have a brain he has an imac
cinema
i love that so any idea he has in the
ins he's able to project it in his head
and view it in all its glory and say
this he knows what it's going to look
like he knows what it's going to be he
knows how it's going to cut and he knows
how a room full of people are going to
receive it you know so that's really
exciting to be around and um so yeah
absolutely that that action scene is is
definitely an iconic moment out of the
whole kingsman franchise that was
brilliant absolutely reese uh we we have
to ask uh your your performance as
rasputin is it it's bat [ __ ] it's just
batshit awesome and
it's uh one of the wildest things we've
seen all year and it's glorious how how
much freedom did you have in adapting
such a larger-than-life character with
so much historical mystique i mean was
there
i was just so curious about the process
you know some might say way too much
freedom no no i loved it
you know the thing is look if you
marry a figure like a real-life figure
like rasputin with a franchise like
kingsman there's going to be a lot of
fun you know because rasputin himself
was almost a figure from from king's man
anyway he's all he's almost like some
kind of anti-superhero
um there's so much myth and legend and
mystique surrounding rasputin the real
guy you know i was saying to someone
earlier you know most most guys in
europe at that time
pretty much had exactly the same haircut
you know but rasputin seemed to stand
out you know it's like he's running the
devil's
you know wellness clinic
you know um the guys
like you described batshit crazy he was
described as the mad monk you know i
mean people would gather to watch him
eat he ate like like like wolves you
know um that there'd always be food in
his beard he stunk to high heaven he
never watched and but still there was
something attractive about him you know
women would would swoon his feet women
boys and dad i say probably you know
goats and piglets
the man's sexual appetite had no balance
so you know
all everything i brought said rasputin
on the screen is based in fact you know
that's that's the extraordinary thing so
we just you know matthew just tweaked it
and turned it up to 11 where it was
necessary and you know that we we played
around yes so that's what happened it
was absolutely delicious and definitely
just as sexually attractive as you were
describing it
yes 110
and speaking of attract
jaime i mean shola is such a charming
and warm character but also you know he
can kick a whole lot of ass and he's
existing in you know a pretty unfriendly
and unintegrated time anyway did you
draw any inspiration from real life
figures in building that character and
being that shola is so close with oxford
in the film ray finds character did he
work with you on building that
relationship
uh of course i uh that was um
a bit of a my own
fantasy of about shola and a bit of a
couple of historical figures that i've
picked from
uh those figures were senegalese of
origin uh they
also were
in the front line for the french
revolution and then never talk about it
and it's almost like these guys have
contributed to the the the peace of uh
in europe and you know and yet uh
nobody ever addresses that and so this
was a take on
their journey also
back then yeah i mean it was a little
bit of reflection on that a little bit
of my own fantastic look on chola and
certainly you know freedom of expression
here because obviously we're having a
fictional story here so obviously it
gives me uh you know license to a sort
of like a plate however i see it fit but
it was uh he was a very organic
character within that setting so well we
found it very sincere and uh
how do we have to wrap this up the last
question
um you guys like i mentioned earlier you
actually guys co-starred in films that i
particularly grew up on watching a lot
rhys i'm sure a lot of people have
associated like notting hill with you a
bunch and jimin i know you've been like
oscar caliber films like amistad blood
diamond but funny enough the film i grew
up on with you the most was actually the
movie deep rising
and oh
and it's making me i was just kind of
curious to ask yes are there any films
in both of your filmographies that you
reflect on or revisit periodically uh
jimin we can start with you well first
of all i don't really uh revisit my
films uh
too much um
they're good
it's worth it
but uh you know
uh for nervous reasons uh uh but um
interesting you mentioned um
uh that one uh that preceded the amistad
of course uh which was uh
yeah
no i mean i'm not sure yeah no i don't
really okay forget my film so therefore
that's my answer
yourself
yeah i well i have one i i'm
particularly still fond of and
it kind of
it didn't necessarily fly at the time
but i remember it with such affection
and it's still a film i i love and it
kind of reflects the sort of movie
or world or storytelling that i enjoy
and it's a film called human nature okay
um it was a charlie kaufman script yes
directed by michelle gundry starring tim
robbins patricia arquette
myself peter dinklage appears in it um a
great crazy little movie you know where
i where i play um
a kind of
uh
child it's like an anti-tarzan film yeah
um where this guy is taken from uh
living in this federal
uh he i think he's raised by recess
monkeys and then tim robbins who's a
behavioral scientist
discovers him in the forest and brings
him back to society and attempts to
civilize him and he's able to teach him
table manners and everything but they
can't
they can't quell his um kind of sexual
desires there's a theme yeah
yeah i appreciate jessica he continually
is humping things like a dog
[Laughter]
thank you both so much uh this is one of
the highlights of our year uh thank you
both so much and uh people are gonna
enjoy the hell out of this thank you
very much happy holidays happy happy
holidays take care hi my name is greg
alba and i'm john humphrey and we are
the real rejects knocking each other's
microphones out
hi harris uh it's an absolute pleasure
to meet you thank you so much for taking
the time to talk with us you're great in
the film thank you so much for being
here well thank you thank you so much
yeah nice to talk to you guys loving the
chairs
oh thank you so that's we only bought
them for the compliments so i really
appreciate that we've never even
actually seen any of these characters on
screen
our first question to you this is
something that was really popping up
into our mind when watching this was you
get to work with so many great and
formidable actors in this movie between
gentlemen hansu recipients gemma and of
course uh ray fines who you spend a
great deal of time with on screen
what was it like bouncing off of so many
incredible actors and being that ray
finds plays your father did you guys
work closely together in developing your
specific character yeah i mean do you
know what rafe and i
were lucky in the sense that we we got
along immediately we had a good uh
rapport i was very nervous to work with
him i was in
but i i was you know i was intimidated
by his by his body of work he's someone
i've admired for
for years and same with gemma and jimin
and rhys you know they're all people
that i've watched and sort of marveled
at throughout the years so
when you're
faced with the uh possibility to you
know share
the screen with them it is it's
intimidating but they're all such lovely
people that they put me at ease very
quickly and
i just felt like we were able to
play and and try stuff out and
yeah i think it's like also hard not to
just want to
watch what they're doing when you're in
a scene with them because you just start
you know getting lost in it and just
being like that was really good that you
know that
you know
well to your credit i really feel like
you you held your own and i feel like
that is an actor's dream come true
absolutely
and i mean you know this movie is an
interesting one for conrad because
obviously he gets to occupy both the
world of the gentleman spy for part of
it and then you know going into a more
authentic sort of world war one set
piece uh which proves both brutal and
pivotal for your character um the scene
in no man's land especially with that
you know particular fight was one of our
favorites i think across the whole movie
and so i was wondering you know if you
could talk about uh preparing for that
like the grueling process of shooting
those trench and battle sequences
yeah yeah
i you know
early on matthew said to me you know how
much do you want to do physically and i
sort of saw that as a little bit of a
challenge and was like well i'll do as
much as i can you know i'd do everything
and then
later realized that um how hard that
would be you know how physically
demanding that would be but i had a
trainer for like six months leading up
to it that run me through a lot of like
military stuff he was an ex um he was an
ex paratrooper and so we spent a lot of
time together and just kind of
conditioning my body and you have these
absurd moments when you're
you go to work and you go home and
someone was like oh how was your day and
it was like yeah it was good i was i was
learning to do these knife side fights
and i was like crawling through forests
with the next paratrooper
i always do and it's like it becomes so
absurd that what you do at work each day
so i was lucky man i was lucky in a
sense that i got put through my paces i
picked up new skills and
yeah
you kind of have to when you're doing
those things because it is so
it is so well orchestrated and planned
that all these different elements if you
mess up and you don't do your moves
right or you don't hit the marks
correctly you know you're gonna get a
bit of shrapnel in your face or you're
going to get hit by a certain weapon and
it's like it's it's you have to be
precise with it well i thought it was
visually beautifully realized and and
another just compliment to you as well i
don't want to just make this a
compliment section but but the the
following moment i don't want to do any
spoilers but the following moment that
was a very emotional moment for conrad
was especially a highlight for us uh in
our viewing experience watching that as
well the gentleman spy is a classic
character archetype
almost like a special club for british
actors i'd imagine
was there anything in particular you
were hoping to bring to this kind of
character and how did you go about
balancing that more rough and tumble
aspects of portraying a soldier well if
i mean if there is a club i have not
been invited to it
if you find of any sort of secret
members club i'd love to know about it
because i feel left out
but um i don't know i think
conrad is someone who really wanted to
he wanted to be defined by his bravery
and that might sound corny but he at a
time where everyone was kind of being
judged by that you know you everyone was
so quick to deem everyone as um
as cowards for not serving a calls but
the reality is is that that no one
really understood
what that would mean for them no one
understood the human cost of what the
war would would would be and i think um
i just tried to also bring that element
into it you know that eagerness and i
think that's something that
is common now is that people are willing
to go and
um serve and very admirably serve for a
cause that is is beyond them you know
absolutely yeah i think it shines
through definitely yeah yeah um i think
one of our both of our favorite things
uh to hear about you know especially on
a movie like this is just the type of
conversations that might have been had
off camera between takes and being like
we said before you're surrounded by so
many veteran actors and you've got a
director like matthew vaughn just what
would you guys talk about between takes
when the camera wasn't rolling and was
anybody particularly funny or friendly
or you know impart any sage actorly
wisdom
well ray you know rafe is notoriously um
uh
serious about the craft and that's
incredible but he also has a
an ability to be
funny and
and sort of silly in between which is
something i didn't expect but john and i
had a scene where we were sparring um
and we had our tops off and it was like
a little bit cold and
i know that uh
simon and i were both very cold so i
feel like we both just spent the whole
two days just sort of looking at each
other and being like yeah i'm cold yeah
yeah you can't yeah yeah it looked great
yeah both of you eight plus
uh i guess my last question would be um
matthew vaughn in our opinion is one of
the best directors working today and
this film sees him balancing so many
different tones and outlandish
characters historical figures and
whatnot what kind of vibe does he draw
on set and did any of it make sense in
the room
he knows what he wants he's very he's
very straightforward with with his
direction he doesn't beat around the
bush which i appreciate you know i'd
rather complete honesty he's not afraid
to
to shout out across the set a bit a
piece of direction you know he's not shy
in that sense you know i remember a
scene where where we uh i was just about
to start and
he was like don't be [ __ ] and
i love that it might have been right
yeah i'll try not to be but um but that
was fine because and i like that because
he you know we'd already built a rapport
and he was leading the charge as such so
yeah i think like with the film like
this there's a lot going on he's very
you need someone at the helm who's going
to stay calm and keep it all sort of
flowing in the right way and he does
that well yeah
well that's awesome to hear uh thank you
so much for your time i think people are
really going to enjoy the hell out of
this movie and congratulations again is
a whole blast of a film thank you so
much thank you guys nice one take care
cheers
you